müsten diese
Ängste planvoll schüren um sie für ihre
verantwortungslosen Pläne zu
missbrauchen die Nachricht über
ausbürgerungspläne wonach
Rechtsextremisten Millionen Menschen
selbst deutsche Staatsbürger vertreiben
wollen wir haben unser Land aufgerüttelt
in ganz Deutschland sind hunderttausende
aufgestanden auf die Straßen gegangen in
den großen auch in den kleineren Städten
Alt und Jung Menschen mit
unterschiedlichen politischen Heimaten
Menschen die deutlich gemacht haben wir
wollen Rechtsextremismus in unserem Land
nicht haben nicht dulden und das was sie
gezeigt haben war ein starkes Zeichen
für unsere
Demokratie ein Zeichen allerdings auch
das nötig war ich habe heute morgen
Wirtschaftsverbände Gewerkschaften und
Betriebsräte
eingeladen weil ich aus langer Erfahrung
weiß immer wenn es ernst wurde in
unserem Land wenn es um das gemeinsame
ganze geht dann hat die Zusammenarbeit
der Sozialpartner geholfen Krisen zu
bewältigen und neue Herausforderungen zu
bestehen natürlich haben Unternehmer und
Gewerkschaften zu vielen Fragen der
Gegenwart unterschiedliche Antworten
auch zu Parteien und
Politik aber ich weiß dass sie eines
eint das Eintreten für unsere Demokratie
und die entschiedene Ablehnung jeder
Form von Rechtsextremismus ganz gleich
ob Vorstand oder Vorarbeiter und ganz
unabhängig von der
Parteizugehörigkeit wenn unsere
Demokratie angegriffen wird dann ist
eine Grenze überschritten bei der
Gegensätze
hintanstehen dann muss die demokratische
Mitte die große Mehrheit unserer
Gesellschaft Position beziehen und
deutlich machen wir stehen zu unserer
Demokratie wir verteidigen dieses
Deutschland und wir lassen uns dieses
Land nicht von extremistischen
Rattenfängern kaputt machen die
Sozialpartner stehen für diese
gesellschaftliche Mehrheit die
Sozialpartner Unternehmen Gewerkschaften
Betriebsräte wissen am besten dass der
Kampf gegen den Rechtsextremismus auch
ein Gebot der ökonomischen Vernunft ist
nationalistische abschätung Abschottung
das Gerede vom Austritt aus der
europäischen
Hass auf Menschen mit
Migrationsgeschichte diese Ideologie der
Extremisten ist Gift für unsere
Volkswirtschaft Gift für Arbeitsplätze
und Wohlstand sie ist eine Gefahr für
unser Land Wirtschaftsexperten aller
Institute warnen in diesen Tagen mit
dramatischen Worten vor
selbstmörderischen Wirtschafts und
europapolitischen Konzepten die unser
Land in den Ruin treiben würden damit
ist noch gar nicht über einen
Arbeitsmarkt gesprochen auf dem mehr als
ein Viertel der Menschen die Arbeit
gerade von denjenigen erledigt wird die
die Rechtsextremisten am liebsten
ausbürgern wollen das sind Menschen die
an der Supermarktkasse stehen LKW Bus
oder Straßenbahn fahren in Hotels und
Restaurants Arbeiten Autos Häuser und
Wohnungen bauen an
Forschungseinrichtungen Universitäten
Impfstoffe entwickeln und viele
Unternehmen
leiten was wären wir eigentlich ohne
die aufgeschmissen sind wir aber auch
wenn es nicht gelingt zusätzliche
Arbeitskräfte ins Land zu und ich komme
gerade aus Vietnam und Thailand zurück
glaube niemand dass die Veränderungen
der politischen Stimmung bei uns dort
unbemerkt bleiben unsere Glaubwürdigkeit
die ist nach wie vor hoch aber Fragen
nehmen zu
ich danke der deutschen Wirtschaft ich
danke Unternehmen Verbänden
Gewerkschaften Betriebsräten die meine
Einladung heute gefolgt sind sie
bekennen sich zu ihrer gemeinsamen
Mitverantwortung für die Zukunft der
Demokratie und stellen sich Extremisten
entgegen das ist ein gutes Signal für
unser ganzes Land und ich bin sicher es
wird gehört werden in den Unternehmungen
und Betrieben in
Deutschland für die Sozialpartner haben
BDA und DGB heute eine gemeinsame
Erklärung verfasst die heute noch
veröffentlicht wird und ihnen
zugeht so wie auch Demonstrationen
gehört werden brauchen wir jetzt ein
breites Bündnis quer durch die
Bevölkerung quer durch Unternehmen
Kultur und Gesellschaft ein Bündnis
gegen Extremismus und für unsere
Demokratie wir alle wissen ein solches
Bündnis allein kann noch nicht den
Unterschied machen Demonstrationen und
Bündnisse der Sozialpartner
ersetzen auch nicht Politik wir brauchen
Regierungen eine Opposition die ihre
Arbeit gut machen aber auch dieses
Bündnis könn den Blick auf das
Lenken was uns verbindet es kann uns Mut
machen gemeinsam Verantwortung zu zeigen
ich danke meinen Gästen dass sie dieses
heute vorgemacht haben vielen Dank danke
schön Ihnen auch so wir können nach
nicht